[Musique]
pour la première fois depuis 13 semaines
la musique résonne dans la maison
symphonique l'ouest m est de retour à la
maison
on peut jouer et oui tout seul dans
notre salon mais le vrai répertoire de
violence y est fait pour être joué en
communauté et ben là c'est aujourd'hui
c'est une petite communauté on est
seulement 15 mai c'est notre coeur
d'orchestre qui se remettent à abattre
les musiciens ont enregistré un concert
qui sera mis en ligne sur facebook et
sur le site de l'ouest m jeudi à 19
heures
[Musique]
le protocole sanitaire est stricte
obligation de porter le masque fabriqué
par une musicienne de leurs qu'istres
distanciation physique le retour sur
scène ne signifie pas un retour à la
normale pour ce qui est de l' écoute on
est beaucoup plus dispersées sur scène
c'est une écoute complètement différente
donc on a dû s'adapter à ça en
répétition beaucoup un peu redécouvrir
notre espace parce qu'habituellement on
joue à ces groupes et malgré
l'annulation de plus de 70
représentations les musiciens de l'ouest
m n'ont pas chômé ces dernières semaines
leurs capsules et concerts virtuels ont
été vues plus de 2 millions de fois
kent nagano devait diriger cette semaine
le dernier concert de la saison
régulière les adieux devront attendre
l'ouest m attend impatiemment les
consignes gouvernementales pour savoir
quand il pourra retrouver son public en
salle mais plusieurs scénarios sont
prêts on joue différemment quand on voit
l'expression qui change sur leur visage
quand on fait quelque chose de beau
quand on sent collectivement que 2000
personnes think i qui respire avec nous
qui vivent des émotions avec nous donc
encore l'os et c'est doux amer d'être
ici sans eux on est content c'est la
première étape
en attendant les retrouvailles les
mélomanes pourront patienter avec des
oeuvres de mozart et de voir jacques
interprétés par des musiciens heureux de
se retrouver ici nabi alexandre chartier
radio canada montréal
[Musique]